more Americans are planning to travel
overseas next year a recent survey found
international travel bookings jumped 44
percent for early 2018
despite the expected rise Americans are
more frustrated by air travel Americans
say they avoided an estimated 32 million
plane trips last year because of rising
fees flight changes crowds and long
lines CBS News travel editor Peter
Greenberg is here with what you need to
know about traveling in the new year
Peter good to see you good morning so
some of these low-cost airlines
Norwegian air is one of them they're
adding some different routes in the US
and you're saying that may change things
airfare oh yeah well you know 2017 was
the year of the disruptor Airlines 2018
even more so Norwegian already flies to
14 US cities and they're gonna add
routes this year to Madrid Milan to
Amsterdam think about this they're fly
to airports that are underserved
Hartford Providence Fort Lauderdale and
they're doing it so it fairs that you
can't believe New York to Ireland for
like you know $65 and Los Angeles to
London for a hundred and seventy-five
dollars but they're just one of the
disrupter airlines
we're seeing airlines coming in to Costa
Rica Vallauris a Mexican discount
carrier flying from three US cities and
of course you're seeing airlines like
Southwest the original disrupter airline
is now announcing they're flying to
Hawaii this coming year and you know
what if the Southwest effect is in
effect and they're actually claiming
this right now air fares on that route
we're going to come down across the
board does that do do the disruptors
change some of those bigger companies as
well there are fairs they do I mean
that's the Southwest effect I mean every
time they've come into a market air
fares drop substantially they expect
that to happen again that's good for
consumers yes cording to one survey 60%
of Americans feel that they've seen
airline fees increase over the last year
Oh they've not only seen them they felt
they felt them yes well can it relief
for 2018 oh no home of the brave and
land of the free
welcome to we are talking about airline
fees going even higher this year not
just in terms of the airline tickets or
the ticket change fees on some
international flights the ticket change
fees are up to 750 dollars okay so get
ready for that and it's going to get
worse because that's where they get most
of their revenue the airlines are making
more money now from ancillary fees and
they're making from operating his
Airlines Wow Peter let me ask you
quickly about
that's become a popular destination for
people fly or take a boat
well the the recent trouble
administration rules we're sending some
of the Obama rules basically meant
people thought you couldn't go to Cuba
oh yes you can all the Trump
administration did was say they're about
more than 80 hotels in Cuba owned by the
military that you can't stay at cruise
lines are exempt from that they're
adding capacity cruise lines are
actually adding more cruises to Cuba
right now Airbnb has obviously changed
the hotel market what's that impact been
well the the hotels it serves a year of
rapid explosion in the hotel business
Marriott right now right this minute is
opening up one new hotel every 14 hours
Wow I mean you can't even do the math on
now
but Airbnb now also controls 6 percent
of the total rooms in the world and you
know what that's only getting bigger and
what what's really happening is do you
want to stay at a cookie-cutter hotel or
do you want a more genuine experience
and that's whatever B&B is doing now
they're in the experience business not
just in the alternative hotel business
and you're also predicting more
Americans will be experiencing cruises
as well in the new year 16 new cruise
ships coming online this year every
every shipyard in the world is operating
at 100% capacity but this is for a
business that's actually in its infancy
so the capacity means discounts coming
this year yeah millions of Americans
just saying get me somewhere warm thank
you you guys happy new year